[موسيقى]
تتمثل رؤيتنا الأساسية في جعل الأرض خضراء
مرة أخرى
عن طريق إيقاف وعكس اتجاه
التصحر وتدهور
التربة السطحية الحيوية
[الموسيقى] ،
لذا فإن ما اخترعناه حقًا هو
الطين الطبيعي السائل الذي يُشار إليه أيضًا باسم
الطين النانوي السائل أو lmc باختصار.
هي
عملية
تحول التربة الرملية حقًا
إلى بنية تربة تحتفظ بالمياه
والمواد المغذية تمامًا مثل الإسفنج
، ولهذا السبب ننظر في كيفية
تطبيق الطين على الأملاح التي لا
تحتوي على الكثير من الطين
وأسهل طريقة  وجدنا أن القيام
بذلك هو تسييله بطريقة
نقوم بها بطريقة طبيعية لا نضع فيها أي
مواد كيميائية أو
إضافات لذلك لدينا
منتج طبيعي بالكامل يمكنه استعادة
الأراضي المتدهورة
وتوفير المياه في هذه البيئات
فيما يتعلق  المناطق
التي تتطابق معها هذه التكنولوجيا بشكل قوي
ويمكن أن تزدهر فيها ،
أود أن أسلط الضوء على أي نوع من المناطق التي
بها نوع من
المناطق الصحراوية التي تعاني من
التصحر وكذلك في المناخات الصحراوية
ليس لدينا الكثير من الأراضي الصالحة للزراعة ،
كما أن الأراضي التي لدينا والتي
نزرعها تستهلك الكثير من المياه
لزراعتها وصيانتها ،
لذلك من خلال تطبيق الطين السائل على هذه
المناطق ، يمكننا أولاً وقبل كل شيء
تقليل كمية المياه اللازمة لزراعة الغذاء
و  زراعة المناطق في ظروف الصحراء
ونرى أيضًا أنه يمكننا إنشاء
أراضٍ صالحة للزراعة يمكننا إنشاء تربة
تحتفظ بالمياه بعيدًا عن رمال الصحراء
مباشرةً ،
وستمكننا هذه التقنية أيضًا تمامًا من زراعة أنواع مختلفة من
الطعام التي يصعب نموها في
هذه البيئة
[موسيقى
] من الأشياء التي بها الكثير من المناطق هنا
في الإمارات العربية المتحدة والشرق الأوسط
هي الرمال والصحراء ،
وهناك أيضًا الكثير من ضوء الشمس
، ويمكننا أن نتحول إلى حلول إيجابية
باستخدام هذه التكنولوجيا لزراعة
الغذاء لتعزيز الأمن الغذائي و
تقوية استدامة كوكبنا